well Beijing has kicked off its
Communist Party Congress which will
ensure a third term for Xi Jinping he
will enter his second decade of rule
with a less robust economy but more
control over China and its citizens
which has also meant a More
nationalistic Country fueled on more
propaganda so far the actual events of
the Congress have been pretty dry with
no clear surprises from his speech
though overseas analysts are parsing and
debating every word one thing to keep an
eye out for whether he'll even hint at a
possible successor one of the world's
most powerful men does not appear to
have a succession plan which is always a
challenge for any country
we have journalist sulin Wong joining us
from The Economist she and her team
recently put out a multi-part podcast
series about Xi Jinping entitled The
Prince which I highly highly recommend
it's very engaging so sulin why don't we
start by asking if viewers are to take
away anything about Xi Jinping what are
the key things we need to know
what's important to understand about Xi
Jinping is that he's driven by power
he's incredibly ambitious he has this
sense of entitlement and an
understanding of Chinese history and he
is also motivated by China's future so
what do I mean by this he had an
incredibly traumatic childhood even
though he was born into Communist Party
royalty when he was nine years old his
dad was purged and he was attacked and
given five minutes to live by Mao
zodong's mobs he was then sent to live
in the countryside for seven years in a
cave so he had this really scarring
childhood and that has really shaped who
he is because while millions of his
generation thought that's it I'm done
with China because they had that that
similar experience what makes Xi Jinping
really interesting is that he had a
different takeaway and what he realized
was what he decided was that it wasn't
the Chinese Communist party in and of
itself was bad even though it had
inflicted all that trauma onto so many
millions of Chinese what he decided was
that the party had lost control during
his childhood and so if he ever Rose
through the Chinese Communist party and
if he ever Rose to the very top he would
make sure that that kind of chaos
wouldn't be repeated and he was going to
make sure that he would prioritize
control above all else so understanding
his childhood but also understanding his
um family helps us understand why he's
doing what he does today
it certainly explains things although
some people can interpret it as massive
Stockholm syndrome so how would you rate
she's performance as a leader the past
decade what would be his grade
when cgp came into Power 10 years ago
the Communist party and China were in
crisis that corruption was rampant there
was political infighting at the very top
of the party and Xi Jinping seized
control of the nearly 100 million
members of the party through his
signature corruption Crackdown and
really by ramping up ideological
discipline once he seized control of the
party he was able to use it to seize
control of China and what we've seen is
Xi Jinping develop incredibly
sophisticated censorship surveillance
and propaganda machines and China itself
has become a lot more repressive and a
lot more authoritarian over the past 10
years so from his perspective he's
actually been incredibly effective at
achieving what he believes is right for
the party and the country but of course
whether it's actually a good thing for
the Chinese people whether it's a good
thing for China and the rest of the
world is an entirely different question
and I would argue that actually what Xi
Jinping has done to China is incredibly
dangerous not just for the country
itself but for the rest of the world
and that really leads to the question
about what China's neighbors should
expect as he enters his second decade in
power what do they need to worry about
what we're seeing from Xi Jinping is he
wants to create a world that is safer
for the Chinese Communist party so that
China can go about doing what it wants
to do both domestically but also in the
rest of the world and what the main tool
that they're using is their economy
because China's economy has grown so
much you know over the past few decades
and also since Xi Jinping came to power
and increasingly what we're seeing is
China is wielding its economic might to
bully other countries to coerce other
governments and businesses and
individuals and as China becomes even
stronger and even more powerful we're
going to see more and more of this type
of economic coercion in the whole of
Asia and around the rest of the world
and that's going to cause a lot of
tension hostility distrust and conflict
sulin Wong thank you so much for joining
us and once again do check out her
podcast it is absolutely excellent
thanks Melissa
it seems like nothing is to distract
from jijing Ping's moment China on
Monday delayed the release of third
quarter growth figures along with other
economic indicators expected this week
the likely reason well the 20th Congress
of China's Communist party is underway
in Beijing and xingping is expected to
win a third term as the party's General
Secretary amassing more power than any
Chinese leader since Mao Zedong but Mr
she must take on some difficult tasks
especially the economic instability of
the country the Chinese economy is
facing extreme turbulence in the second
quarter the economy grew by just 0.4
percent compared with the same period in
2021 the World Bank has also lowered its
forecast for this year from five to two
point eight percent the biggest reason
for this is the government's rigid zero
covet policy several cities and
different regions are still incomplete
or partial lockdown they are responsible
for 30 percent of China's GDP growth now
as a consequence of these lockdowns
residents are buying less products
factories and ports remain closed and
Supply chains remain Disturbed now let's
take a closer look here what's at stake
at the party Congress and for China
overall with the DW's China analyst
Clifford coonan here in the studio and
with York woodkim he's the head of the
EU chamber in Commerce of Commerce in
Beijing welcome to both of you uh York
let me start with you did you find any
positive news for Western companies in
uh XI jinping's speech yesterday
well it was all about ideology and
aligning the country uh behind him uh
it's this week is a victory lab for him
so there was nothing that's going to
disturb the masses so there was not much
on specifics when it comes to business I
think there are more worries for us than
good news so particularly the topic
about self-reliance China feeling uh the
heat from the US and trying to basically
become less dependent on globalization
and hence that's not good news for us
Clifford over to you um China's State
and party leader says we're going to
stick with the zero covert strategy Xi
Jinping has hailed this as a success
why does he want to stick to that if
it's so detrimental to the country's
economy well at this stage it's it's a
policy that he will be judged on and um
because he started early and he did have
early successes now there's no
scientific reason or very few scientific
reasons it's just too infectious the
Omicron variant
um so the reason he's staying with it is
because
um he he kind of he stuck with it now
politically it's very important that he
stays with it and also uh the country's
health system is still very much in
development so it would be quite
problematic I think if if there were a
major outbreak there so he's basically
sticking with it for that reason uh York
back to you so with China uh holding on
to the zero covet strategy I mean we've
seen that companies uh have been looking
for alternatives to China we see that
investment of EU companies in China has
been declining is China going to become
in parenthesis just another foreign
market
no it's certainly the size Wise It's too
important in particular for car
chemicals Machinery uh those companies
in that Fields have to invest more and
more is just too big and too important
but you you're right in many ways uh
companies are looking at Alternatives
we're not moving out of China we are
looking into India southeast Asia even
back into the European Union in order to
see where we can do stuff and uh of
course the longer China Waits with the
zero tolerance policy the more the
movement is for new investment going to
other places something which of course
there will be irreversible so China
inadvertently is opening the doors in
other countries for European investment
Mr she also said that he's not ruling
out Force when it comes to what he says
uniting Taiwan with China how prepared
are Western companies in China should it
come to that and the subsequent
sanctions
well I mean nothing new there he has
always been saying if there's a the red
line it's the travel Independence and
they always indicate that they will use
Force I don't see any more at the
Horizon anytime soon
um of course the the blockade during the
Pelosi visit was a sort of a warning
shot at the same time China is as
dependent on the Taiwanese semiconductor
supply chain as are we and in case
there's a blockade or let alone a war of
course it's not just China being
impacted the whole world goes down in
flames
uh Clifford back to you here in the
studio
um what will beijing's future Economic
Policy which is somewhat today's
Economic Policy what they're going to
hold on to mean to Citizens and
consumers around the world
well I think um what we're seeing in in
this Congress is um quite there's quite
a lot of rhetoric around common
Prosperity
um and dual circulation and uh which are
quite vague um I think what you're
seeing is more if you as you see more
stage interference in the economy
um you're going to see things uh much
more of a focus on the domestic market
and I think that means that for for for
companies outside of uh outside of China
for example it's going to become quite
difficult particularly with the
political stresses we've seen that Joe
Biden has just introduced new sanctions
on new restrictions on Tech transfer
which means that American Americans
working for the companies there are are
quitting so it's it's going to have
quite a serious impact DW's Clifford
coonan and Jurg vodka the eu's head of
the Chamber of Commerce in Beijing
thanks to you both